[Music]
at long last fans of dc comics once
again have a reason to buy a ticket at
their local movie theater to kick off
their packed dc slate for 2022 warner
brothers released the batman on march
4th courtesy of director matt reeves in
this non-dc extended universe flick we
see the titular dark knight played by
robert pattinson in the midst of his
second year as an armored vigilante
however he's not up against petty
thieves and robbers this time around
rather he has to contend with an
intelligent and dangerous entity known
as the riddler batman's beware spoilers
ahead
throughout the batman edward riddler
nashton turns the entire city of gotham
on its head instead of going on a
mindless murder spree he meticulously
goes after several individuals in
positions of power killing them and
publicly dragging their names through
the mud all the while he leaves a series
of codes ciphers and riddles to keep the
gotham city police department and batman
on their toes thankfully they eventually
end riddler's sadistic revenge game and
stick him in arkham state hospital but
not before the final stage of his master
plan could begin riddler acted alone for
most of the batman until the tail end of
the film his numerous followers from
dark corners of the internet stepped out
of the shadows to help him out although
something about these underlings didn't
sit right with several moviegoers during
his reign as one of gotham's most wanted
the riddler conjured up quite a
following online as the gcpd
investigated his apartment they searched
his laptop and noted that he had roughly
500 online followers folks that have
listened to his every word and taken his
messages of violence to heart these are
the ones who showed up in full riddler
garb with every intention of firing upon
scared and helpless people at gotham
square garden who huddled there due to
riddler's flood-inducing destruction of
the city's sea wall the thing is all 500
of those followers didn't actually show
up in fact the final tally was likely
less than 100 and those that have
already gone to see the movie took
notice one user on reddit's the batman
spoiler discussion thread poking fun at
riddler's fickle fans commented only
like 10 people actually showed up for
the big event lol this prompted a
discussion about the serial killer's
failed attempt at gathering forces to
carry out his plan another redditor
added i liked that thought it was very
realistic in fact i'm surprised he got
that many to show up and a fellow user
posits that probably only 10 were
trained and willing to go through with
the plan nevertheless they were no match
for batman catwoman jim gordon and the
rest of the gcpd together they took down
these keyboard warriors turned gunman
before they could really start wreaking
havoc at the end of the day it should
come as no surprise that good ultimately
triumphed over evil in the batman the
riddler wound up behind bars the bulk of
his devoted followers failed to deliver
on their online promises and batman
earned his place as a true hero in the
eyes of gotham's residence still as
evidenced by the aforementioned reddit
thread it appears as though paul dano's
chilling twist on the riddler left a
lasting impact on fans in spite of the
character's murderous tendencies and
obvious inability to find on his cronies
of course a redditor commented best part
for me was ripler every scene with him
was amazing and numerous other folks who
checked out the batman recently echoed
similar sentiments one user called
dano's performance quote creepy and
unsettling as a realistic riddler should
be and defended his over-the-top
mannerisms as perfectly fitting for this
version of the famed batman rogue in
expressing their love for the overall
movie another user compared riddler to
the real life zodiac killer suffice to
say the unsettling similarities are hard
to ignore there's no denying that paul
dano's riddler was an excellent foil for
robert pattinson batman and could easily
remain a thorn in his side if the batman
lands a sequel or two should he manage
to escape arkham and continue
terrorizing gotham city however he might
want to look into enlisting some better
henchmen perhaps then he could actually
succeed at his evil schemes but then
again it stands to reason that the caped
crusader and his allies would more than
give them a run for their money check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
batman are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you